okay the United States has checks and
balances and limits on power for a
reason
well actually for many different reasons
but one reason that we have checks and
balances and restrictions on power is
that we want to prevent a president from
becoming tyrannical now I'm not playing
coy in any sense I'm using a word that
sometimes the right uses but in essence
you want to have a system that would not
allow a president if they so desired to
become tyrants or total authoritarians
or autocrats and one of those
separations is that the president is
separate from the Justice Department the
president decides who is the Attorney
General yes but the president is not
meant to get involved in or attempt to
interfere in or direct particular
actions of the Justice Department this
includes investigations this includes
recommendations on prosecutions and
everything else that would sort of
follow from that the president should
not is prohibited from interfering or
influencing any kind of individual
operations of the Justice Department and
that has a pretty far reach and scope in
terms of what the Justice Department
does we have now a report in The New
Yorker which says that Donald Trump was
directing his former economic adviser
Gary Cohn to put pressure on the Justice
Department to block that merger we've
been talking about between AT&T and Time
Warner and this is that merger that for
political reasons Donald Trump didn't
want to see happen Time Warner owns CNN
from paté CNN Trump talks about CNN as
fake news Trump has gone to battle with
individual CNN reporters and with CNN as
a network more broadly he says it's all
fake and he wanted to block the merger
as punishment now this is really
important for progressives to be clear
morally on on what our position should
be here these mergers are terrible for
everyday Americans okay I've been
speaking about the dangers of media
consolidation for a decade on the
program at this point the wave that
fewer and fewer
owners of media entities narrows the
scope of discussion it's terrible
ok in principle the government has an
interest in preventing such mergers for
the benefit of consumers however the
president's personal disgust with CNN is
just not a valid reason to try to block
the merger the White House has insisted
that Donald Trump played no role but
that can be merely a sort of legal
statement right in no particular
tangible legal way did Trump play a role
in the decision but this report is very
specific and it says that in 2017 Donald
Trump got on the phone with Gary Cohn
and his then chief of staff John Kelly
brought them into the Oval Office to
quote make sure that the Justice
Department would file a lawsuit to stop
the merger from happening one reported
quote from Donald Trump to John Kelly
I've been telling Cohn to get this
lawsuit filed and nothing's happened
I've mentioned it 50 times and nothing's
happened I want to make sure it's filed
I want that deal blocked now to his
credit Gary Cohn reportedly refused to
bow to pressure from Trump and said it
would be quote highly improper which is
true and that's the right thing for Gary
Cohen to do in fact Gary Cohen was
reportedly so mad that he said to John
Kelly don't you effing dare call the
Justice Department we are not going to
do business that way John Kelly has been
asked about this report has declined to
comment
a spokesperson for Gary Cohn has been
asked about this report also declines to
comment so I want to put aside like
every other concern about Trump's
activity and every other investigation
every other instance of possible
criminality
if this allegation is true it's an
impeachable offense I'm not saying it's
a crime because I don't believe that it
is but this would be an impeachable
offense and you only need to go to
Kellyanne Conway's own husband George
Conway Kellyanne Conway is an advisor to
Trump her husband George Conway tweeted
quote if proven such an attempt to use
presidential authority to seek
retribution for the exercise of First
Amendment
rights would unquestionably be grounds
for impeachment understand the logic
here okay
this is actually a first amendment thing
99% of what the right says our First
Amendment issues issues about free
speech actually aren't because they
don't understand the First Amendment the
First Amendment says Congress shall make
no law respecting an establishment of
religion or prohibiting the free
exercise thereof or abridging the
freedom of speech or of the press or the
right of the people peaceably to
assemble and to petition the government
for a redress of grievances if the
government meaning the executive the
executive branch Donald Trump is putting
pressure on the Justice Department also
the government to punish a corporation
for the way that they use their right to
speech which happens to be something
Trump doesn't like it is a violation of
the First Amendment period this is what
abuse of power looks like this is what
authoritarianism looks like it's yet
another sign of it and there are many
with Donald Trump we know he loves
authoritarians and he seems to dislike a
lot of our Democratic allies he slams
the media as the enemy of the people a
new one this weekend he's giving
outrageously long speeches another
hallmark calling heart of the
authoritarian autocratic dictatorial
types he likes the idea of president for
life as he expressed after Chinese law
was changed with that regard attacks the
court system when he doesn't like their
decisions the problem is the judges a
very authoritarian and then now he wants
to punish media outlets via the Justice
Department for their reporting on him in
a way that he does not like this is an
authoritarian danger to everything that
we consider to be important about
American democratic institutions and we
can't allow it to continue